[Music]
major league baseball's long history is
filled with dramatic moments but one
thing they all have in common is the
substance that was applied to the
baseballs before they were put into play
brook silva braga is here with more on
that good morning brooke good morning
dana well if you're ever lucky enough to
snag a major league baseball like this
one my four-year-old came away with from
fenway park this summer the first thing
you notice is that it is not gleaming
white like a new ball before every game
dozens of game balls are rubbed with mud
and long beforehand that mud is dug up
by hand by one man
at the end of a suburban street
somewhere in new jersey how often are
you out here
at least once a month jim bintliff led
us through the woods this is the spot at
the bank of a tributary of the delaware
river gotta watch us step down
we reached jim's own strange secret
field of dreams
what's so good about this mud the
geology of this area is um unique we had
promised not to reveal the exact
location uh my boot might be staying in
new jersey and when his assistant
no-showed agreed to help with the work
all right here you want me bring the
bucket over
at the end of his shovel the peculiar
mud jiggled like pudding
what i want is the sediment
that is a mixture of clay and sand
for three generations jim's family have
been the only people carefully
harvesting the only substance legally
applied to major league baseballs do you
remember your first time coming out here
first time i ever shoveled mud i was
nine years old and who brought you out
with my grandfather
the story of the mud starts with tragedy
in 1920 ray chapman was fatally hit in
the head by a pitch with an old dark
ball
[Applause]
baseball soon mandated new balls for
each game but they came slippery from
the factory in search of a better grip
lena blackburn a major league player and
coach found this special mud by his new
jersey home
before long it was the major league
standard lena blackburn and my
grandfather were
childhood friends they used to fish and
swim around here when lena found the
need for the mud in baseball he and my
grandfather would come out
and
do this
blackburn eventually turned the business
over to his friend who turned it over to
his son
who turned it over to jim it's a gift
i love this
this ain't gonna be easy
but hauling 45 pound buckets of mud back
through the woods
is no walk in the park
jim eventually plans to pass down the
grueling business to his daughter and
son-in-law the next time a pitcher grabs
a ball doesn't like the seams and throws
it in the crowd
i'm gonna take personal offense
i don't
to change
[Laughter]
but the charming homespun nature of lena
blackburn baseball rubbing mud still
processed exclusively in jim's garage
is a bit out of step with the modernized
optimized direction of today's game it's
a romantic story it's great but it's
2022. we've got to find a better way to
treat the basements last year major
league baseball crack down on the
equally old tradition of pitchers
sneakily using foreign substances on the
ball
and that hit him this year coincidence
or not pitchers complained the balls
were too slippery the mlb has a very big
problem with the baseballs
and they're bad everyone knows it every
pitcher in the league knows it what did
you make of people complaining about the
balls being slippery this year well i
could tell them it's not my mud
my mud has not changed
but in response to the complaints last
month mlb announced new league-wide
standards for exactly how to apply the
mud i spread it in my palms
which is meant to remove the factory
gloss without leaving behind easy to
grip scratches all they do is they'll
massage it around at least that's how it
works for now
other grip substances have reportedly
been auditioned this year in the minor
leagues do you worry at all about them
not wanting to use the mud anymore
that would bother me if they decided not
to
there's a couple words i'd have for him
but
[Laughter]
it wouldn't kill me
in addition to the big leagues spin lift
ships mud to many minor league college
and even high school teams as well the
latter can get by on one small 25 jar
per season
for most of his life jim worked as a
short order cook
his dad was a carpenter his grandfather
a baker
but this unique family side hustle has
managed to sprinkle a dusting of the
bent lifts onto the fingertips and bat
barrels of every baseball moment you're
likely to remember does this still
register to you when something big in
the sport happens
guy hits a record-breaking home run wins
the world series yeah that your mud's on
the ball yeah
yeah that's why i do it
i ain't getting richier that's why i do
it